damn my face is shiny as hell hello
everyone hope you are well and I really
hope you didn't catch coronavirus oh god
what a state the world is in these days
huh but it's okay we will adapt we will
make it through because that's what
humankind has done for millions of years
ok so a lot of companies in the Bay Area
and I'm sure in other places are
enforcing such really strongly
recommending everyone to work from home
to prevent the spread of kurodo virus so
I thought it would be a really good
opportunity for me to talk about helpful
tips in working from home for some of
you this might be like your first time
working from home and for others this
might not be anything new because you
work from home usually anyways
regardless I wanted to share some of my
tips for how I work from home because I
definitely started a place where I had
no idea how and now I love it I love
working from home every job that I've
worked out for like the last four years
I have had at least one work from home
day per week because I find that it
really helps me regain my balance and
ground myself so that I'm not just at
the office for like 40 hours a week
which is kind of a lot and while the
corona virus is super scary and it keeps
getting scarier so don't forget to wash
your hands y'all I think one of the
silver linings and this is that we might
work more towards a remote work culture
as a society is an industry which is
something that I am personally really
excited about because especially in the
Bay Area where cost of living is super
super high traffic is really really bad
I feel like work from home culture might
really help to mitigate some of those
effects and might allow other people who
don't want to live in Silicon Valley or
can't afford to live in Silicon Valley
to work at Silicon Valley companies and
I know that remote work does have its
implications in that sometimes people
say that it makes them work for longer
hours because it's hard to separate
between work and life I think that as
long as you keep some structure to
yourself and that you have
some routines that you like to follow
and that you figure out something that
works for you then it can totally work
and I know this some of y'all are like
the ones that just like really want to
go to the office because you just want
to see people and I feel the same way
because I currently identify as more of
an extrovert but right now we're in a
pandemic still stay at home and don't
spread germs and don't get sick so we're
in this together Yael and I wanted to
share my tips and tricks also if you
have any tips and tricks of your own
leave em in the comments down below as
always so let's get this thing started
and before that if you were maybe
brought here by the algorithm and to me
then thank you algorithm and hello my
name is VY Yuko I make videos about tech
and lifestyle and career advice stuff so
please consider subscribing or just
watching some of my other videos which
I'll link up here so the thing that I
wanted to address first is kind of the
theme that underlies all of these tips
that I'm going to talk about which is
about structure so when you're working
from home you're literally in the
comforts of your own home and I know
it's really enticing to just rest and
chill and watch TV and do whatever and
if you want to that's fine that's your
own truth whatever but for me when I am
in the mode of hey I want to do stuff
and I want to get work done then
creating some structure in my day-to-day
so that I get there seamlessly and
easily without needing to pull my mental
state along to get there that's I think
really an important part about having a
successful work from home environment
so the first tip is to stick to your
usual routine for going to work because
that sets the stage for the rest of the
day and kind of the tone for the rest of
the day so kind of try to do all the
things that you would normally do on a
workday just - the commute so those are
things like waking up in the morning at
the same time as you usually do and I
know it's really enticing to stay in bed
because you don't have to go anywhere
and stuff but starting off your morning
at the same time helps your body
remember that hey we're going to do
things today and waking up at the same
time in the morning helps kind of start
off the domino effect of all the other
things that are happening so waking up
at the same time make sure that I walk
my dog at the same time in the morning
and that's really important to me
because I get some fresh air and I get a
little bit of light exercise in before
my work day I also eat breakfast in the
morning I am a breakfast person if I
don't eat breakfast I get really hungry
and I can't think and I'm just a very
cranky person so I usually eat what I
normally eat like a bowl of really good
oatmeal or a Japanese breakfast to help
myself get into the state of things are
going to happen today and I have like my
morning tea or my morning coffee I have
my water it's like really just all of
the same stuff that I would be doing to
prepare for a regular work day
so step number two goes as hand-in-hand
with the morning routine which is about
getting clothes and getting yourself
physically ready for a work day again I
know it's really enticing to just stay
in your pajamas all day but I think that
at least getting out of your pajamas
into something else it doesn't have to
be like exactly what you would wear to
work like I hate wearing jeans and I
wear jeans to work so I don't wear jeans
on my work from home days and said I
really like some loungewear on the
bottom but it does help me to get out of
my okay I'm done sleeping mindset and I
always wear like a shirt or something
that I can make sure that I can hop into
a call really easily without feeling
embarrassed or sloppy and for me getting
ready also means like putting my makeup
on because that helps me get into the
mindset a lot of this is just getting
yourself and your body into the mindset
of working I'm say out putting makeup on
like I usually do in the morning like if
I was going to work also helps me to get
there tip number three is about your
working location so I know again really
enticing to work from your bed because
it is the most comfortable place in your
house but get yourself out of there find
a spot that you were going to call like
your office if you have a desk at home
like I do then great spot if you don't
then your dining room table is a great
spot also like your living room couch is
a great spot just somewhere other than
your bed or somewhere that you see as
relaxation and having a space that you
can claim that you can just call your
kind of mental space is really important
because having a space like that helps
you to better contact switch between
work and home as well and so make sure
that this area is clean make sure
that it is quiet make sure that it's
somewhere that you can take phone calls
or video calls really easily in case you
can get a hop on to something I think
just having a location first something
like that is really important for
working from home
so my next step is more kind of like a
piece of advice
than it is like a tip yes and it's that
it's okay if your workday working from
home looks different from your workday
working in the office because let's be
real you're in a completely different
place you're in a completely different
environment and so I think that having a
little bit of flexibility there and not
pressuring yourself not expecting that
you're going to before I'm the same way
or do the same amount of work or
communicate in the same way I think is a
realistic expectation to have and I
think it relieves you of the stress and
pressure that you might put on yourself
for working from home and I know before
this tip I talked a lot about getting
your mind set to a place of okay I'm
going to work from home but also I think
it's just like a balance like what's the
balance that you want to have between
like feeling like you're at home and
working from home versus like emulating
working from your office as much as
possible and I think that's probably
going to be a different answer for
everybody but I think it's a realistic
expectation I have to know that your
work from home day is going to look very
different from your work from office day
so for me once I realized that it was a
little bit more forgiving and I had a
little bit more flexibility in how I set
my time and I think the biggest change
that I incorporated into my life that
helped with this was to just take breaks
because brakes are important when you're
in an office you take breaks when you go
to the bathroom while you're getting a
snack when you join a conversation
that's around your desk with your
coworkers I think you'll notice that
there's actually more breaks than you
think that you take at work but when
you're home there aren't as many
distractions maybe or maybe there are
but I think that including breaks into
your day to day and sometimes even
scheduling them or just being mindful
that you're at least taking one or two
breaks a day helps you concentrate
better throughout the rest of the day so
I take breaks during the day buy like go
to the bathroom making myself some more
tea I'm taking my dog out on an
afternoon walk to get some fresh air
I also like to make lunch at home when
I'm working from home because I feel
like it uses a completely different part
of my brain from coding and also eating
and sometimes I'll just like watch TV
while eating too and so those breaks are
really important to me because they help
ground me and create that like okay I
can rest my brain from the work that
I've been doing like 20 feet away and
just let myself like relax a little bit
so that I can reset for later
so my next tip is to communicate really
well with your teammates when you're
working from home so this tip will apply
to a lot of people who work on teams
especially in the tech industry which is
where I'm coming from but it's really
important to communicate really over
communicate when you're working from
home especially because you're not
seeing like actually seeing these people
that you're working with when you're
working from home making sure that you
communicate on slack or discord or
whatever team chat that your team uses
what you're thinking how you're feeling
and how other people can communicate
with you is a really important part of
the success of a remote work culture so
make sure to tell your teammates how you
want them to contact you because you're
not in a real office then people can't
just come up to you and tap your
shoulder and be like hey I have a
question instead they're most likely
going to communicate to you over a team
chat or email or phone or video chat and
so setting your own boundaries too and
telling them what those boundaries are
really helps to have a successful work
from home day because the reality of it
is is that people need stuff from you
you work on a team after all and so
telling people okay hey I am focused
right now I'm concentrated I don't
really want any distractions and less
than its emergency maybe like setting
your status on slack to tell people that
or putting yourself on Do Not Disturb
I often times will like go into a team
chat and be like hey team here's what's
up like I am available all day through
all of the usual means but I might be
heads down on something so if you really
need to contact me for something then
call me or then email me so that way the
team knows exactly how to get a hold of
you if they really need you and
otherwise if they need to get a hold of
you or you know it's not super urgent
they know how to contact you too and
it's totally normal to expect that lots
of communication is gonna happen over
chat channels and stuff and so making
sure that you are responding kindly
typing in the way that you would talk
helps other people pick up on the tone
of your voice and the tone of what you
were trying to communicate those are
important things when you're not seeing
people face to face and going
hand-in-hand with that previous tip is
to make sure that you were available
during normal working hours when you're
working from home because you work on a
team and everybody works full-time
everyone wants to depend on each other
and needs to depend on each other to get
the things that they need when they need
it so make sure that you're working the
regular hours that you would usually
usually like 9:00 to 5:00 and let people
know if you're stepping away from the
computer or you need to just take a
break for a little bit just let them
know so that they know exactly what
you're up to so that they don't have to
keep guessing like where where are they
like why can't I get any help from them
but I think that helps teammates trust
you and know exactly how to communicate
with you so that they're not left
guessing like when are you gonna be
available so for me I also always make
sure that my sound is on for
notifications and all my chat
notifications are on on my phone I also
make sure that everything's on on my
computer and my computer is fully
charged so that I can respond to
anything quickly showed anything come up
and also being available when you
usually are means that it's also okay to
be unavailable when you're usually
unavailable
make sure to log off at the end of the
day when you would usually leave work
and create boundaries because otherwise
it's really easy to work like a 12 hour
a day so just close your laptop let
people know like hey I'm off for the day
like let me know if there's anything
that comes up but otherwise I'll see you
tomorrow I think creating boundaries
like that between you and your teammate
really helps you to create boundaries
between your work and home too so make
sure they humanik eight all of those
things I know it's can be kind of
uncomfortable because you're talking
about like your boundaries with people
that you might not have ever talked
about before but ultimately that really
helps with kind of your mental state in
your emotional state in working from
home and it also just gets rid of a lot
of awkwardness and tension that could
otherwise exist so I highly recommend
doing this so we're on my last couple of
tips which are all meant to prevent the
kind of stir-crazy feeling that you get
from working from halt multiple
consecutive days I know that some people
in the Bay are already feeling this
because like day three of working from
home and not seeing other people for
that one can be quite a long time for
some folks so rapid-fire some tips that
I have for preventing stir craziness
number one I said it before but change
locations don't stay at your desk for
the full eight hours or don't stay at
your desk every day for an entire week
just change locations within your house
or change you know go to a cafe or go to
like a communal area maybe in your
apartment complex or something just have
a change of scenery and that will help a
lot
[Music]
my second tip is to move your body your
body is probably not gonna move as much
as when you work from the office because
you're not a until walk to places as
much unless maybe I'd like you have kids
at home or you have pets or something
that needs taken care of or whatever but
you're most likely going to be more
sedentary which we're already a very
sedentary group of people so what does
that make us now stone or something like
that so move your body make sure that
you are sending up every once in a while
go on a ten-minute walk once or twice a
day do some stretches because oh man
becoming like late twenty's like my legs
and my back are starting to feel how
long I fit and it hurts so do those
things and also exercise like exercise
is important and especially because
their brains are working so hard then
making sure that our bodies are catching
up by doing some exercise yes do that
please
[Music]
my last tip for preventing stir
craziness is to use a Pomodoro timer
which I think really helps have come the
focus and motivation bit you could work
from home and stay super focused for six
hours a day but I am NOT one of those
people and so having like small
incremental chunks in which I work I'm
gonna take a break and then I work and
then I take a break helps kind of make
sure that I'm changing up things and
that I'm not just sitting there with my
own thoughts for hours on end there's a
lot of systems up there that can help
track your work time and your rest time
I use a Pomodoro timer there's a bunch
of apps out there that you can use to
help you pace your focus time in your
break time but I find that it really
helps me to hone my focus especially
when I'm working from home cool so those
are my tastes are working from home I
hope this was helpful I really enjoy
working from home I actually prefer that
as my default if anything because I feel
like I have more control over my
day-to-day and I can have a more
balanced work-life balance I guess
especially because I can easily contact
switch between work and home better but
I hope that your area is not super
impacted by coronavirus and if it is I'm
sorry but we will make it through we'll
be fine and see this I hope as an
opportunity for how to work from home
better as well as how to be more
compassionate to each other and take
care of each other so that is it for
today I hope you liked this video hit
thumbs up click subscribe leave a
comment be happy don't worry
whatever we want
seven rings or something like that
that's how that song goes right thanks
so much for watching and I will see you
next time bye